me
rem ん
[音楽]
いま世界でコンピューターを使って全く新しい建築が乱され様としていますそれを
アルゴリズム建築と名付けて探求しています
今このような研究は世界でたくさん行われているんですがその中でも僕はおそらく
かなり初期のあの
研究を始めた人間だと桜
います大学時代から研究テーマが情報と建築というテーマで研究をしていました
世界中で研究が進む中で僕はある一つの結論にたどり着きました
それはアルゴリズム建築の可能性というのは秩序と多様性が共に実現できる建築だと
いうことです
コンピューターの神帝によって自然界のさまざまな芸小中にある
秩序ルールが隠れているということが明らかになりました
複雑系の科学という学問がありますそれはコンピューターの技術によって自然界の様々
な現象の背後に潜むルールというものを探っていく
学問です
それによって例えば気流や乱流
木々の樹木の枝らは彼歯の並び方などにさまざまなルールは隠れているということと
いうことが明らかになりました
自然界は非常に多様な三係を持っています
しかしその背後に非常にシンプルなルールをかけている
複雑系の科学はそのことをコンピューターんを使ってアジア借りしました
しかもその父と多様性というのは対立するのではなくてお互いが共存していて
せめぎあっていその状況を複雑系の科学ではカオスの縁を預けて生命という現象はその
父と対応生が頭にせめぎ合っている
非常に危うい状況で生み出されているということ
いくことが今明らかになっています
僕はこの子ちょっと多様性が共にある建築というものがアルゴリズムの方法によって
検知を世界で実現できるんじゃないかと思い
2009年にヴィラ狩野さんと住宅をつくりました
これがそのダイアグラムのですが a
これは千葉君津の山奥に建てられているれっそうなのですが1階に4つの部屋が並んで
2階に4つの部屋が並んでいます
その9分とキューブの間の好転にまた小さなキューブが差し挟まれてそのお互いの
キューブの間が15度という角度によって相互に関連
付けながら回転をしその9分によって
全体の空間がえぐりキー取られています
結果としてはこのような空間が生み出されています
このように一見空間見るとたような小口によって非常に複雑な命係が生み出されている
のですが
しかしその命係というのは掲出 c 的なランダムなものによって作ら伊藤ではなくて
15度という角度の回転角の事例によって明確に定められたアルゴリズムによって
いらされています
そのことによって表明には何百という多様な小口のあり方の背後にあるルールが感じる
あるということを
人は近くすることができるようになっていて不思議な安心感を味わうことができます
いわば秩序と多様性が共にある
たような
世界の背後に[ __ ]が隠れているという複雑系の科学が明らかにした
自然界のありようを建築空間として体験することができるようになっていますトップ
ライトからは光が差し込んできてその光はどんどん
あの空間の中でちー産卵をするのですがそう空間の中で産卵したし
怒りは自然にプリズム効果が生み出されて写真に写らないのですがさまざまな色の光に
よって空間が満ちた状況になります
光というのはこんなに多様な色でできているんだということに気付く
非常に不思議な空間になっています
写真にはちょっと映りませんおっしゃっていません
でこのようなアルゴリズムの建築を探求していくにあたって
a 私はあるあのことに気づきました
それはネットワークという空間のあり方がいかに多様な可能性を持っているかという
ことです
ちょうど複雑系の科学の人たちも同じことに気がつきました1998
1年にアメリカの複雑ネットワークの研究者のダンカンワッツとスティーヴン
ストロガッツという人たちがスモールワードネットワークという二色を
八景しましたこれがその図式です無性にあるものがこの式は
世界のありとあらゆる此の世の中のネットワーク構造の中に潜む
ある数学的な秩序を表しています
そこでは近くのものと相互に様々の方は絡み合いながら
しかし同時に遠く飲もうとつながっているという関係が表現されています
これは通常の私たちが日常の生活が決して経験することがないような子ですがこのよう
な空間の図式が
たとえば脳細胞や神経細胞社会ネットワークからインターネットはでありとあらゆる
ような顔ネットワーク構造に潜んでいるということを
ダンカンはすとスティーヴンストロガッツは数学的で明らかにしました
しかもその知識は痴女多様性の中間にある
来られて
危ういバランスの中で成り立っているということが少し専門的な言葉になりますが
アルファーパラメーターという概念によって明らかにされています
左の図は実情を表していて右のうちは多様性を表してるんですが
真ん中はちょうど辞書多様性がバランシングした
スムーズアートネットワークの頭を表現しています
僕はこの地町対応生が共にあってしかもたような距離が複雑に錯綜する
短い距離と長い距離が同時になる建築空間
そのようなものを作ってみたいと思い実際に立ててみました
これが2013年に大宮の住宅地の中に出来た
エスターハウスという建物です cg のように見えますがこれは実際に立っています
実際にこの現場に訪れるとしかしでもあたかも cg の空間中に紛れ込んだような
不思議な印象を味わうことになります
ことができます
テストガラスによってできた空間なのですが久しと壁と床が複雑につながって空間自体
が
編み込まれているネットワークがと建築です
この空間はリビングルームなんですがリビングルームの一番奥に
ひし形のボイドボイドというのは建築の言葉で隙間を表す言葉ですがその向こう側には
キッチンがあります
そしてリビングからキッチンには知覚的にはメールのですがそのすぐ近くに見える
ちっちの空間
実際にたどり着くためにはものすごく物理的に長い距離送る遠回りしないとたどり着く
ことができません
いやは視覚的に短い距離とナップついて気に長い距離という
2つの距離が同時に存在している先ほどスモールアートネットワークの二色の中であっ
た
短い距離と長い距離というものが2つ同時に存在している
非常に不思議な空間ができていますそういうによって普通の空間感覚というのが距離の
感覚というのはこの空間の中でパクラーされるこ
とによって
4歳の空間の何倍もの大きさの空間を知覚することができるようになっています
次にお伊勢するのがそのネットワークの空間を公共の建築に応用した j のですが今
フィリピンのネグロス島のが腰というところで公共建築をつくっています
この空間は行政が提供する様々なプログラムを受け止める
多目的空間なのですが行政が秋祭りや
付
リーマーケット音楽フェスティバルなどさまざまなイベントを行います
そういうお通しに
観光案内所や市のゲストルームなど街の外から来る人たちを受け入れる
街の外と中の人たちが触れ合うインターフェイスのような空間として設計は伝えてい
ます
このような空間なのですが実際には薄い木材を徐々にずらしだが積み上げてそれ自体も
全て違う曲5でできてそれを積み上げていくという途方もなく手間のかかる作り方が
使われているんですが
現在関西と向かってコーチが進められています
このような建物が新しい地域の交流拠点になることを僕は期待しています
ではこのアルゴリズムのネットワークの空間というものが一体何なのかということを
正祐登まあこれは一言でいうならばおそらく
様々なことを新しく発見することができる空間だということが言えると思います
誰でも小さな頃にも山を駆け巡って自然の中で遊んだ記憶があるかと思います
その時に様々な木々のざわめきや母流れ
数の葬儀見たことない草花を自然の中で様々な新しい発見をしていったことが思い返さ
れると思います
アルゴリズムの建築というのはそのような自然の中で様々な発見をしていく体験に
すごく近いということができると思います
そこで様々な複雑なネットワーク型のある大泉による空間を探求して探索していくと
いろんな世界の物事が新しく見えて新しい発見が次々と
会えていく
そのようなアルゴリズムのネットワーク後の空間を
僕はこれから住宅や商業施設公共建築
後は高層ビルまで至るまで様々なデザインを通して世の中に埋め込んでいきたいと思い
ますありがとうございました
[拍手]